what's principals hard work works in
every country yes
reading books works in what countries
everything every country right wanting
to improve works where everything having
a proper diet works in what country all
country taking care of yourself and
staying clean works on what country in
every country learning how to deal with
people works in what countries anyway
that's what I Bank off that's what I've
been gone now let me give you the other
side you ready to the other side this
prostitution exhibit exists in every
country yes yes do crimes exist in every
country yes do arguments exist in every
country do divorces exist in every
country do bankruptcies exist in every
country yeah so principles and bad
habits are everywhere
you